(suspenseful music)
- I don't know about that.
- [Man] Kardashians are back at it.
They're always obsessed with sushi.
They're always getting sushi.
- Yeah.
- Their dog is named Sushi.
She's making sushi all the time.
- I don't know anything
about the Kardashians.
- I love them.
Super fan.
Huge fan.
Obsessed.
- Kylie Jenner's pregnant, right?
- I didn't even know
Kim Kardashian had kids.
- I don't think she's her kid.
- This is not the first time
I've questioned a Kardashian method.
And I'm pretty sure it's
not going to be the last.
- This is not some crazy,
new, weird hotdog sushi.
- It's kind of like
spam musubi from Hawaii.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, or like that
Korean sausage kimbap.
Just things that we've always had.
- I love hot dogs.
I don't care if they're in sushi.
I'm going to eat the hot dogs.
- If Kim took the time out of her day
to make these hot dog rolls,
I'll try them.
- I'll basically do
anything they say is cool.
- I'm ready for the hot dogs.
I'm ready for the sushi.
I'm ready for the Kardashians.
Bring it on.
(upbeat, dainty music)
(crickets)
- Looks just like I thought it would look.
- I see you, Kim.
- This really isn't so bad.
- I don't know whether I should ask
for mustard or soy sauce.
- To be fair, if they sold
this at an Asian supermarket,
they like did a pack of six,
- Yes.
- Put a little bamboo leaf.
Three dollars.
Totally buy it.
- To Kim Kardashian.
- And Khloe.
- Okay.
Alright.
- It's great.
I honestly like it.
- Because it's literally just like, what?
Rice and hot dogs and seaweed.
- I love it.
I actually love it.
- This is the kind of thing
that my mom would make me if she loved me.
- I like your optimism and
how open your taste buds are.
I'm really feeling it, bro.
- Thank you.
- It's just not my thing.
It's not my thing.
- I think what makes Kim
Kardashian so successful
and the Kardashian family so successful
is that they're really
relatable and aspirational
at the same time.
- It's weird that Kim Kardashian
kind of momentarily shines a light
on something that we don't know about
and everyone's flocking to
this thing that seems weird.
- It's really nothing new,
and it's a great thing to have.
It's not that weird.
- This is not weird.
In college, I would eat like
cheddar cheese and salsa in a wrap.
- I would welcome her
graciously into our family.
Mostly because of her immense wealth.
But also her hot dog sushi.
Great.
Fantastic.
Bring it to the family, friend party.
Everybody will love it.
(dainty music)